[Music]
on this monday night
a brutal blizzard blasts ontario and
quebec canada that's what it is i think
i got stuck about 15 times the traffic
frozen to a standstill
a premier pitching in and the snow day
for kids canada's first stamp of
approval for a covid pill who will get
the drug when and what's known about it
so far a global news exclusive canada's
special forces deployed to ukraine the
mission and rising tensions with moscow
plus making waves across the atlantic
i'll get there when i get there one
man's exhaustive goal to shatter a
rowing record and honor his grandfather
global national with donna friesen
it is winter and it is canada but this
january blast is not your standard storm
a huge swath of southern ontario and
quebec is under winter storm and
snowfall warnings the snow started early
in the morning and plows simply could
not keep up in toronto major arteries
were closed streetcars stuck in their
tracks and people were advised to stay
home schools stayed shut on what was
said to be the return of in-person
learning quebec too has declared a snow
day
good evening and thanks for joining us
it is not that we don't expect any
snowfall it's the amount combined with
the strong winds that's the issue this
satellite image shows what a beast of a
snowstorm this is swirling across the
region toronto is forecast to get
between 40 to 60 centimeters ottawa
between 30 to 50 centimeters
we have complete coverage tonight
beginning with mike drole in toronto
and
it was a rude awakening for much of
ontario and dogs were no exception the
storm came in fast leaving a swath from
niagara through ottawa under a deep
blanket of snow
up to 60 centimeters in parts the
traditional snow belt south of lake
ontario saw white out conditions and
drifts that confounded even the plows
nobody was immune to getting stuck not
even buses and fire trucks
early in the morning commuters who
weren't already working remotely were
urged to stay home and when two of
toronto's largest highways were shut
down because crews couldn't keep up the
city's other arteries turned into
traffic jams it's terrible
i mean i've been driving for 30 years i
have never seen anything like this you
know i mean it's like so many cars in a
in a ditch on the side of the road and
then in the city infamous for calling in
the army to combat snow ontario's
premiere digging out cars and giving
people lifts unmasked in his own this is
doug ford
i'm the taxi driver today toronto never
gets massive snowfall well obviously not
never because i can barely walk down
this road and it's completely impassable
over here
but rarely a typical year we'll see the
top snowfall at 15 to 20 centimeters and
today with well over 30 centimeters
we're looking at a top 10 day in the
city's history
what makes this storm so unique was the
path it took to get here it dipped far
south across the united states before
coming up the eastern seaboard so that
was a bit more unusual usually we would
see a system like this affecting quebec
in the maritimes for once ottawa may
have had a snow day milder than
toronto's although they were digging out
there too making the most of this
unplanned down day it's awfully
coincidental on the day that the kids
are supposed to go back to school that
it one further delay in uh in returning
them to some semblance of normalcy
in that regard this may have been
exactly what kids needed a day to be
kids again to hit the hills with
toboggans in tow and make a snow angel
or two
mike trelay global news toronto
i'm mike armstrong in montreal if
there's a positive from this storm it
may be that it didn't catch anyone by
surprise
it was one of those all hands on deck
operations even before the snow started
falling salt trucks and snow plows hit
the roads and the public was told if you
can stay off the roads
if you have the chance to stay home and
warm that's fine
for the most part people followed that
advice there was little traffic just
about anywhere streets looked like ghost
towns there was actually less
accumulation than predicted but there
were strong gusts
i'm just
yeah worried about power failures that's
my biggest concern because of the wind
yeah
those fears didn't materialize and there
was another positive the temperature
montreal just spent several days in a
deep freeze monday was about 20 degrees
celsius warmer than it's been given the
choice between having snow or frigid
temperatures the choice for some was
simple oh definitely the snow i feel
like i needed a break my face was gonna
fall off
for kids with this snow day there was
little suspense schools announced sunday
they'd be closed extending the already
extended holiday break
we're not supposed to be home the kids
are supposed to be at school everything
was supposed to be back to normal
not yet not yet
after three weeks with a 10 pm pandemic
curfew quebecers can now stay out late
not that there's much to do
bars gyms theaters most things are still
closed
ironically one pandemic measure few
complained about monday was masks well
actually the mask kind of
helps another positive on a day like
today is seeing people help each other
in this case it was a man in a pickup
who pulled a couple out of a snow bank
he was offered cash for his kindness the
answer was a simple absolutely not mike
armstrong global news montreal
lots of kindness today and a final note
about that storm a young ottawa boy is
being credited for saving a neighbor
ottawa paramedics thanked this
eight-year-old they say he located an
elderly man who had fallen in deep snow
and was almost covered the boy spotted
him and had his parents call
911.
now to the pandemic hell canada has
approved the use of an antiviral pill
the drug called paxlovid is the first
at-home covid treatment to get the green
light in canada it could play a critical
role in reducing pressure on hospitals
abigail beeman reports on how the
treatment works and when canadians can
expect to get access to it
add another word to your pandemic
vocabulary paxlovid this is the first
oral kovid19 therapy that can be taken
by patients at home health canada has
approved pfizer's antiviral drug
particularly important as access to easy
to use treatments could help to reduce
the severity of covenanting in adults
who become newly infected
and are at high risk if given early
within the first three to five days of
symptoms pfizer's data shows the drug
can reduce hospitalizations and deaths
85 to 89 percent but delivering it fast
can be a challenge especially right now
with tests tough to get across the
country the public health agency
recommends provinces save it for those
at highest risk but there's a long list
of medications you can't mix it with
affecting lots of already high risk
people and there are only 30 000 courses
of treatment in the country now with a
million purchased in total for this year
we all know that the supply isn't going
to be great at the start
so for the omicron wave itself it may
contribute but it won't be a key
contributor to
the current wave compared to vaccines
they are of course a substantially more
expensive option dr christopher labo
says initial estimates before any bulk
discounts or negotiations were 700
dollars for a five-day treatment
compared to an estimated twenty dollars
per vaccine though the government won't
say what it's paying for either when you
think of it in terms of preventing
people from getting into hospital they
probably are cost effective because
keeping somebody in hospital for five
days is very very expensive
among the high priority groups
recommended to access the drug the
unvaccinated it's much better to be
vaccinated and not to run the risk of
having a severe case of kobe 19 than to
have to be treated and as welcome news
as this approval is it's still early
days we don't even have any
peer-reviewed data on this medication
either right we know
a little bit about the drug based on
what the company has revealed but it
would be helpful if we had more
information there's a second antiviral
drug in the pipeline canada has already
purchased half a million of mercs
treatment with options to double that
that drug is still under review by
health canada donna
all right abigail beeman in ottawa thank
you new vaccination requirements for
truckers crossing the canada u.s border
went into effect over the weekend in
manitoba drivers protesting that new
mandate slowed traffic at one crossing
[Music]
early this morning truckers caused
delays at the emerson border crossing in
what was called a slow roll protest the
new rules mean that when crossing from
the u.s unvaccinated canadian truck
drivers must show proof of a negative
pcr test and then self-isolate for 14
days
in china authorities have issued a
curious request they are urging people
not to order goods from overseas
claiming packages sent by mail could
spread the omicron variant beijing
confirmed its first case of the omicron
variant on saturday officials say they
believe the woman who tested positive
may have contracted the virus from a
piece of mail received from canada four
days earlier authorities say they tested
the letter and found traces of the virus
the woman's home and workplace have
since been locked down and more than
sixteen thousand people have been tested
this is not the first time chinese
officials have linked covid to packages
from abroad experts say the virus is
airborne and it is extremely unlikely
that international mail could transmit
it
i would say it's virtually impossible
for a great package that was shipped to
china from canada to carry with an
infectious virus that would result in a
transmission event and the reason for
that is that we know that this virus
does not survive long on inanimate
surfaces
beijing's first confirmed case of
omicron comes at a bad time for olympic
organizers the games are set to begin in
just over two weeks organizers are now
stepping up measures to try to limit the
spread today they said tickets to
olympic events will be available to
targeted groups only not to the general
public and strict public health measures
will be in place spectators from
overseas were already banned
we have exclusive new details tonight
about a small group of canadian special
forces being deployed to ukraine
diplomatic talks aimed at avoiding armed
conflict are at a standstill and an
estimated 100 000 russian troops are
stationed along ukraine's border michael
couture explains what we know about the
canadian deployment
seesaw is an elite group of canadian
special forces operators and a small
group of them is now in ukraine they're
looking at potential options to support
the ukrainian government and planning
for the possible evacuation of canadian
diplomatic personnel sources tell global
news the deployment is part of an
attempt by nato to deter russian
aggression it's a message aimed at
vladimir putin in response to his
amassing of an estimated 100 000 troops
on the russian ukraine border make him
understand that any possible gain that
he would have from large-scale military
action
or even military success in ukraine
would generate a cost that would be
outside that would be
far more than any benefits another
symbol of support canada's foreign
affairs minister melania ali met today
with ukraine's prime minister under the
guise of trade and economic cooperation
but there's more at play it is a
pleasure for me to come here and
to send a strong message on the part of
my government but on the part of
canadians as well
jolie's presence is part of the ongoing
support canada has provided since 2014
when russia annexed crimea
canada has committed hundreds of
millions of dollars to kiev in the last
eight years and has helped train
ukrainian security forces i think it
does send a message to russia that you
know the who is part of the alliance
that is willing to stand up to them and
and you know show their support and
their through programming through
diplomatic means etc so canada is a
member of that alliance with nato the uk
and united states which sent a
bipartisan delegation of senators monday
to reaffirm its support for ukraine's
sovereignty and some experts believe
this is about more than just an ally in
eastern europe what happens in ukraine
will signal to other authoritarian
regimes in particular china
and therefore it's important for the
west to stand
collectively especially as talks to
de-escalate tensions in the region
seem to be at a dead end
mike couture global news ottawa
moment of impact coming up what's
happened to the people of tonga after
that massive undersea volcano
[Music]
it's now been two days since a massive
undersea volcanic eruption near the
south pacific country of tonga and the
extent of the damage is still unclear
communication remains cut off because
the country's main undersea phone and
internet cable was damaged
new video has emerged showing the moment
it happened atmospheric sensors have
detected large amounts of sulfur dioxide
gas released by the eruption which could
cause acid rain in tonga and fiji today
air forces from australia and new
zealand conducted surveillance flights
aid groups say they're still trying to
determine the impact on tonga
we're roughly thinking up to 80 000
people could be affected but how many of
them are seriously affected
we don't know
the first death to be reported is a 50
year old british woman her family says
she was on a beach with her husband
trying to rescue her dogs when she was
swept away
she loved animals when she started her
charity in in tonga
you know it was to help the stray dogs
that they have there
the impact of the eruption was felt
across the south pacific and as far away
as alaska authorities in northern peru
say two people drowned after they were
caught in the tsunami triggered by the
eruption
there is an update tonight on the water
problems plaguing the capital of nunavut
officials in ocalaweed are setting up a
river water filling station for
residents worried about the tap water
last week the city said trace amounts of
fuel were detected in the water supply
after residents reported a smell
officials say the water is still okay to
drink but they've set up another option
while they flush the system as a
precaution people are being told to
bring their own jugs the water is from
the river so it must be boiled for at
least one minute last fall a kellowed
spent two months under a water emergency
because the water supply was
contaminated by fuel
ahead how a groundbreaking new vaccine
could help ensure no country is left
behind
the way out of the pandemic is
vaccination which reduces serious
illness and death but vaccines have to
reach everyone not just people in
wealthy countries in canada nearly 78
percent of the population is now fully
vaccinated compare that to a country
like nigeria where only about two
percent of people are fully immunized
progress has been slow because covid19
vaccines are expensive complex to
produce and protected by patents
now scientists in texas are working to
overcome all of that
jackson proskow reports
as high-tech covid vaccines have rolled
out in wealthy nations the developing
world has largely been left behind
unable to afford them and unable to
produce them we've done an appalling job
of actually sharing vaccines and
ensuring that the world is vaccinated
it's an urgent problem epidemiologists
have warned the next virus variant could
emerge in a highly unvaccinated
population the way delta and omicron did
we are only going to get in front of
this pandemic and have vaccines widely
available when you have vaccines that
are being
produced locally distributed locally and
are made at scale researchers in texas
have found a way to do just that
developing a vaccine called corbivax
it's based on traditional vaccine
technology that can easily and cheaply
be made almost anywhere we think it's a
game changer many manufacturers can make
it they have all the ecosystems in place
dr maria elena botazi and dr peter hotez
started their vaccine research after the
2003 sars outbreak when kovitt 19
arrived they realized what they had
and then of course when we saw the
sequence we said oh my god this is like
80 percent similar to the tsar sequence
what's more they're making the vaccine
formula free to anyone who wants it no
patents no licenses simply a gift to the
world when you're in a crisis you really
want to do things that are morally
imperative and that you know that you
address the urgency in clinical trials
the two-dose cobravax has proven 80
percent effective against the delta
variant studies into omicron and
boosters are ongoing
in india one manufacturer is already
planning to produce 1.2 billion doses
per year look if you want to develop
vaccines there are for the public good
you need to share your knowledge in
developing their vaccine the researchers
hope they've created a global model for
tackling future diseases one driven by
the need to save as many lives
everywhere as quickly as possible
jackson prosco global news washington
conquering the atlantic next from europe
to america why he's going it alone in a
boat
celebrations are just getting started
for this guy jonathan a giant tortoise
he's believed to be turning 190 this
year which makes him the oldest living
land animal and now he's got a guinness
world record under his shell too he's
the oldest living colonian that's a
category that includes turtles terrapins
and tortoises jonathan lives on the
grounds of the governor's residence on
the island of saint helena arriving from
the seychelles way back in 1882
well slow and steady wins the race and a
british man is attempting to live by
that rule he is attempting to row solo
without any help from europe to north
america jack jarvis hasn't hit the
halfway mark yet and he's already
dreaming about his next epic fundraiser
crystal gamansing spoke with the 28 year
old about his trek across the open
ocean a tiny speck in the atlantic jack
jarvis is rowing unsupported from europe
to north america and he's trying to do
it in 100 days more battling wins from
the south
every time i stop rowing i'd be pushed
in the wrong direction with every
punishing stroke he's hoping to raise
money for brain tumor research a tribute
to his grandfather it was a massive part
of my life crystal um
you know one of the big male influences
first male influences on my life his
brutal endeavor has raised more than 25
thousand dollars so far
but he's got a lot of ocean left to
cover
we found him in the middle of the
atlantic where he's been rowing 14 hours
a day for more than 40 days
and he's been doing it without a
critical survival resource
i didn't bring enough coffee bags so
i've only got enough for one a day
so it's i'll have to i have to reuse it
if i want uh multiple coffee today so
that's pretty tough that ability to
laugh and adapt are proving important
for the 28 year old the hardest thing is
probably just the missing people back
home his time alone on the water
thinking about his granddad can bring up
a wave of emotions he's sharing those
insights along the way documenting his
journey on social
think people need to media out and get
after it you know push themselves
challenge themselves because the sense
of satisfaction afterwards is so much
better than you know anything you get if
that's true the endorphin rush may
produce all out euphoria when he reaches
land in florida hopefully in march 16
miles in the wrong direction
is what it is
you know it's not looking great
testing his strength spirit and what he
can manage
on only one good cup of coffee a day
crystal gavinson global news
london
and that is global national for this
monday i'm donna friesen tonight's your
canada is this pair of otters in
qualicum beach british columbia we'd
love to see your canada please email it
to viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye-bye
[Applause]
[Music]
you